thank you thank you for coming I was not
expecting uh so many people especially
that the that we are finishing the the
conference so thank you
um
but uh without further Ado let's just
start or someone is going
okay no no no no problem thank you for
being here
okay imagine this it's Monday the last
print of your project you just had a
planning
and you agreed with your team that you
have just two bags to fix and
documentation to finish and you're done
and you'll be done you'll be ready for
the release
you feel good it's Monday but you feel
good you feel excited about the release
about putting stuff out there about the
new project that is approaching
you feel good you feel that this is
achievable this is achievable
it's Monday but it's a good day
on Tuesday uh
engineering manager comes to your room
or zoom and she says look I think it
would be great
if we just ran this project through
through security before the release
and in this context
it would be great means we must do it
so you go to the S so you go to the
meeting with security team and they ask
you so many questions and even more
questions and question based on the
documentation that you haven't finished
yet
and after this one hour torture a
meeting sorry
um
you end up with this
tons of bags to fix and if you ask me I
also have no idea what a snail is doing
up there
so I've been in this situation way too
many times
wait many times and and every time after
releasing a project we would have this
wonderful meeting called in our in my
team called project retrospective does
it seem does it ring a bell raise your
hands yeah we love those project right
perspectives don't we and and every time
someone would raise this problem that
hey we're having the security review
just before the release it's so
stressful
and yet the moment the door closes we
would all we would all completely forget
about this problem and we would repeat
the circle over and over again
for the context my name is Victoria
dollar I've been a work in tech for over
10 years mostly on back end but two
years ago I changed teams and I moved to
security and I was
I had this great opportunity of staying
in the same organization
but in a different role and suddenly I
realized a lot of things changed so I
would go to meetings with Engineers who
were my peers like a week ago and then I
would be considered as this person who
brings troubles and problems and you
know I would even be considered as a
stakeholder which is something that I
would never like to be considered as
since I'm a vegetarian uh
so I but you know working on like this
different side of Side of Moon I
realized that there are some things that
you can do as an engineer to improve
your life and improve the security of
the application or product you're
working on today I'm I will bring
something what I find the most powerful
and something that I wish I had known
before uh when I was a software engineer
by the way uh all of the notes for this
talk are available on this website which
is my website slash security and so know
what oh okay people are taking photos oh
wow okay
um so yeah no worries about taking notes
anyway
um
okay so there are many problems with
security I think we can agree about that
but the main I think is that security
how we think about Security in a product
team
so first we have designers and product
managers product owners however you call
product people who think about security
solely as an engineering problem
and engineers
we as Engineers we are so focused on
delivery and we're so focused on scoping
the the solution so that it's their
deliverable and we're so focused on
finding the uh the most valuable product
that we pull that we see the security
features and we all label them as night
nice to have
they don't they never cut the the first
release and we just put it on this
beautiful shelf nice to have we never
look at it
but to be completely Fair security
itself is a huge Challenge and I it's a
problem basically I like to think about
security as an ocean because
it's big
it's huge have you ever stand in front
of an ocean or a big sea raise your hand
okay
so I don't know if we we have the same
experience but when I was 11 I saw the
Baltic Sea for the first time and it was
a big c for me and I was like
wow there is a lot of water here
so security is just that it's like you
have
application security infrastructure
security you have Cloud security of I.T
Security in application security itself
you have threats you have
vulnerabilities like ah where do you
start
and the problem it's really a big
problem I
guess
that if I ask each of you
separately
how do you know that your product is
secure each of you would present a
different answer
because how do you approach ocean do you
start with a like a one drop or do you
start with the beach I don't know
but here's what I bring you today the
help hopes Hope Street
because look
Security Experts that are much more
smarter than I am agree that security is
this big dangerous thing and we agree
that there is an infinite amount of
threats for each of your products for
each of uh think you're doing there is
an infinite amount of threats we cannot
just list all of the threats and all of
the vulnerabilities that your
application has because we every day we
don't know about some
zero day vulnerabilities Etc and
but
even if the amount of threats is
infinite
all of them can be assigned to one of
three categories
and when I first learned about it I was
like what
because basically what it means it means
that you can put the whole freaking
ocean into three packets
and that will be enough
those categories are called
confidentiality integrity and
availability
which is known in the security Theory as
the CIA Triad and I could use this
opportunity to make a joke about spies
but I don't do that because the only
spice I like Are Spice Girls
so
so here we have the math autistic photo
of three buckets that I could found in
the internet and yeah the CIA Triad is
such a powerful easy like simple idea
but so powerful and let me just explain
why but before I say that let's be on
the same page what confidentiality
integrity and availability mean
confidentiality means that we want
secrets to be secret
when we are exchanging emails in the
future because you can you you want to
tell me that you really liked my talk
and
okay that was a long stretch I know okay
if we exchange emails for whatever
reason uh or you exchange
emails with whatever person you want I'm
sorry this is like tiring
um
you want only you both to to be
available to read it you don't want
anyone else to be able to intercept and
and read your emails right this is what
we know and this is confidentiality
secrets to be secret integrity means
that we want to get what we expect so
every time you log into your I don't
know Instagram account you want uh to
see
your posts your followings your
followers your DMs
um if they disappeared one day you would
be at least concerned right
integrity and availability is means that
we can always access the information
um
we can send the defend email
2 am in the morning or 11 o'clock P.M it
doesn't matter it's always available
so how is it helpful
you know now what the CIA Triad stands
for but how is it helpful for you how is
it how it will impact your work in the
future
so it is helpful because it transforms
the way you can think about security
because right because right now if you
like think about the ocean you don't
have to think about the ocean anymore
you don't have to focus oh do we are we
protecting against this vulnerability or
that vulnerability no instead you ask
the question
and the question is how can the ca of
this project that I work on be broken
and I want you to to to to to step back
and think about
the project uh you're working on right
now think about it
do you all have it in your mind
say yeah sadly huh
I'm sorry but do you have it right yeah
say yes I know
you can ask this the CIA question for
this project
so you can ask how the Cai how the
confidentiality integrity and
availability of your thoughts here be
broken
of course one question will led to other
questions and for each confidentiality
integrity and availability you will ask
sorry different questions but the thing
is that is beautiful because it will
work for you no matter the project
you're working on no matter the the
technology you're working on no matter
if you're a junior developer senior
developer product manager it doesn't
matter if you work for on mobile devices
or you work in devops or you work on
backup it doesn't matter you can always
ask this question as I said this one
question will lead to another and for
each you will ask different questions
for confidentiality you can ask
who can see these results how do we
store Secrets do we log sensitive data
it will of course depend on what uh what
the what problem you're trying to solve
for integrity you'll ask who can create
update and remove a resource what
happens when Manchester's data is send
is the input sanitized are we protecting
against cross-site scripting for
availability of course when we think
about availability the thread is DDOS
attack and most Developers
a very comfortable
um ignoring availability and when I talk
about it and they say oh this is like oh
availability infrastructure group but in
reality you as a developer when you are
introduce a new service to your product
or a new library like you are
introducing a dependency so you need to
ask the question what happens when this
uh dependency for some reason is
unavailable does it mean that oh when
the uh this beautiful software that we
bought for I don't know managing feature
Flags is down does it mean that our
whole product is completely uh
completely completely useless
right you need to think about this you
need to
um
and what I want I'm weirdly passionate
about the availability I must admit and
you need to think about it too
so
when should you do this
you know already what the CIA Triad is
why is it so powerful
okay but life is life developers life is
busy you have already so much things to
care about
when should you do it
so I cannot answer this question without
shifting mentioning shift security left
shift security left is this oh how hard
this trend is in application security
right now like you touch it and you have
blisters basically shift security left
what does it mean so
we live as developers in software
development life cycle do we know this
do you know this like say yeah yeah okay
my favorite honestly
software development lifecycle have this
uh five phases
analysis design implementation testing
and evolution but it's also called
maintenance and release
the thing is I don't know about you but
after a decade in Tech I know that this
is
because
have you ever experienced living in like
working this software development life
cycle
from my experience friends we live in
software development timeline where you
also where you obviously have analyze
design develop test maintained but then
the moment a project is released you
move on to a next project and you never
look at your project again unless there
is some bug
or company decided to invest more money
because oh it's selling right
so when we look at this timeline wink
wink
um then what happens what what I what I
tell you at the beginning like we had
this Security review already on the
right side of this timeline right right
very close basically main to maintain
slash release phase right
so shifting security left means hey this
is terrible for everyone this is
terrible for developers because it makes
us more stressed it adds work it's
having
having to make changes in that on that
side of
[Music]
um
timeline is extremely expensive it
requires more time let's not do it this
way let's shift security left which
means let's talk about Security in the
basically analyze and design phase
so what you can do you can ask the CIA
questions in the design phase and why is
it so amazing and I encourage you to do
it because
you take this I don't know graph or
something you want to design of
something you want to build and you ask
these questions and these questions the
answer will require some changes right
but the changes you make you make on a
piece of paper
they they cost you basically nothing
there's very fast to implement because
they are on a piece of paper or some
digital version of a piece of paper
right
that is beautiful and have emojis
um
so
when you do that
it it opens a new door to you it opens
the it uh it develops your uh security
mindset and you become and you have a
better confidence in shipping something
and building something that is safe so
how do you how can you implement the CIA
Triad so we already know what the CIA
Triad is we know when to do it in depth
that the sooner the better but how do
you do that so first of all like talk
about if you work in a team talk about
it with your team I think there's
frustration about Security review in the
like very close to a release will be
shared among your peers so present this
idea to to your team discuss it with
them like discuss how you can you know
fit uh this uh
in the CIA try it into your practice
and I like and you know it can be like
an hour meeting or something and don't
do it alone
I I encourage it to be like a
cross-functional discussion also with
designers also with product people
because security is uh in reality like
everyone's
um everyone's uh problem I'm sorry
um
and make it part of your process make it
visible for other developers so what I
did uh at content for my previous
company I added
um the security part in as CA Triad in
solution brief enhancement proposals
requests for comments so people were
four years when they were creating this
uh a new a new proposal like how to do
like that the security is an important
part of it and they need to like think
about it and design with security in
mind
there is no week where
without a bridge there is no week
without a new vulnerability found
um I think it was fun when tech
companies were built in garages
but we're past
that phase I would say and I would love
to see our industry taking
responsibility of what we're building
because move fast and break thing is
over
secure building security
with security mind will be
a winner for you like it will be a
winning factor for your business for
your product and I encourage you to
start with the security the CIA Triad
and with the CIA questions to build with
more confidence
um
more secure products that's it thank you
[Applause]
thanks very much Victoria one of the
most entertaining talks of this
conference
there are a few questions on slido if
you haven't added yours yet feel free to
do so now we have a few minutes left
before I answer I just want to say that
I may look confident I'm not so I'm a
little bit nervous so if I if if my
answer don't satisfy you uh pardon my
brain all please reach out on LinkedIn
uh so we can discuss more okay so it's a
safe and friendly space I I believe
right okay please you're doing great
um no I lost my questions no I'm getting
nervous okay
does your security team take part in
each back-end project to help with CIA
or do you do work on dedicated security
projects uh so
um back back at my previous company
we were basically we had a security team
and we didn't have back-end teams we
have product teams that were
cross-functional and basically the flow
would be that at the kickoff of uh I
mean the design phase we would come to
um to assess to have a session with the
with a product team and we will just do
some kind of like this the CIA Triad or
threat modeling
uh yeah and I if you have security team
in you or security someone in your
company I encourage you to air to engage
with them early on yeah
any specific tools we can look into as a
beginner or Junior Dev to introduce
security to our projects yeah I love
this question everyone wants to know the
tool the tool is anything you
are like this can be because I like you
we um I saw it way too offend that we
have like uh we let's buy this tool so
we have a better culture around security
for example right but it doesn't like
every uh every new tool creates a
fraction because all people need to
learn how to use it they are people need
to learn how to use it and implement it
so if you for example I don't know use
Miro for a designing a system then Miro
will be fine for doing uh this CIA
session uh if you uh there are
specialized Tools For Thread modeling
thread modeling one of them is called
but uh like I don't stress too much
about tools it can be done on a like on
a
wide board with some sticky notes it
doesn't matter like just start doing it
and then maybe add a tool when you find
Value in it
thanks this question I don't understand
maybe you can make sense of it did
security to the left improve your
relationship with your old peers
yes yes
um great talk but this is not a new
problem this this person's asking why do
you think it's so hard to sustainably
include security what structures have to
change
oh because you know security is a cost
do we care about equality in this
industry do we like it it's like a
matter of principles I think
it's more like philosophical question
I'd be happy to have a like a longer
child or very over a beer about it yeah
where to start if there's no security
team
Jen ask questions the CIA question I
mean and even if you cannot answer
questions it's fine uh sometimes just
and also by the way I should have
mentioned that that even if you know the
risk or that your your design will
introduce summary sometimes there are
risks it's called risk management
we agree to some risks it doesn't mean
that you have to build a Flawless
flow less secure secure maybe it's a
recording so I will maybe not but it
doesn't have to be like oh the grass
software ever from the get-go but not
just the like exercising this idea is
very important so if you don't know if
you don't have a security team or
engineers in your company just start
yourself ask this question and it will
open some doors for you anyway
and follow up to that I guess how do you
convince the management of the
importance of security so to allow time
being spent on it and
then
this happens you know and I I think
about Uber you know how they
had this few a few months ago uh this
security breach and next day they have
six open positions for security team
you know I mean I understand that
sometimes it's a you know a cost and you
just want to ship also the
but again culture in this industry you
know like if if your investors require
you to just
deliver features new features and new
shiny and even more brilliant features
but always new then of course Security
will be considered cost quality will be
considered as as cost
um and you don't fight this you you
cannot find fight this as a developer
alone
yet I believe that shifting security
left when you when you think about when
you invest an hour of your time in their
design session to think about to think
about security I think it will in uh
return as a big investment for you like
at least you have confidence that what
you're building is secure
wonderful closing statement thanks very
much again please give another hand of
applause
[Applause]
and I think you mentioned all your
materials on your website yes will you
also be uploading the slides for anybody
interested yes you can upload them to
the schedule yeah yeah all right thanks
very much
and I think this was the last talk
regular talk now's the closing session
so thanks everybody for showing up
participating and enjoy the rest of the
day thank you
[Applause]